Ransom takes the snap and it's a shovel
pass to mccringleberry oh he's at the 10
he's at the five and touchdown Rino oh
my great block by hard dunach chud and
that's going to be tough for the Cougars
to come back from boy what a career day
from Hingle melberry the rookie out of
Penn State oh he's just amazingly fired
up here today Jeff you got to love the
way this guy plays and he oh oh see now
there's one pump well I cannot believe
this kid you got to put your team first
in situ like this and mccringleberry's
just not doing that now there's two Jeff
now if he pumps a third time he will
draw his third penalty for
today everybody here waiting with bed
breath he did it oh did he yes he did it
oh that's he couldn't help him amazing I
mean come on in professional football
it's really it's a shame that's what it
is